let's create a matrix which has three
rows and two columns
yes three rows and two columns
matrices are named using capital letters
we can call this one matrix a now there
are a few super basic things we need to
know about every matrix just three
things first what are the elements in
the matrix second what is the order of
the matrix and third what is the
position of an element in the matrix
just three things elements order and
position of every element let's zoom out
and understand each of them in detail
elements are nothing but the components
of the matrix this matrix a has six
elements 3 1 - 2 4 - 1 and 6 that's all
6 elements in this matrix and the
elements of a matrix don't have to be
numbers they could also be letters or
random characters so the elements
arranged in rows and columns make up a
matrix what is the order of a matrix
then this matrix a as we can clearly see
has 3 rows and it has 2 columns 3 rows
and 2 columns the order of this matrix
is 3 by 2 yes this is the order of this
matrix
don't forget the number of rows first
and then the number of columns next we
come to the position of an element every
element in a matrix has a unique
position but how do we define the
position of an element it's easy we look
at the row in which it is placed and
then the column yes row comma column so
in this matrix 8 what will be the 1 1 F
element what does 1 comma 1 mean in this
context first row and first column this
is the first row and this is the first
column 3 is the 1 1 at element so what
is the 1 2 s element in this matrix
first row
and the second column it will be one
this goes on and the last element would
be the three to earth element third row
and the second column it will be six the
row number comes first and then the
column number and the same applies to
the order of the matrix number of rows
by the number of columns writing the
order as 2 by 3 will be incorrect the
number of rows will always come before
the number of columns so let's try
understanding these concepts with an
example the matrix given to us is 1/5
minus 2 we have been asked to find its
order the 1 3 at element and the 2 1 at
element pause the video and try to
answer these three simple questions okay
let's zoom out and try answering the
first question look at the matrix it has
one row and three columns one row and
three columns the order of the matrix
will be 1 by 3 now for the second
question they have asked us for the 1 3
at element this position implies that
the element is in the first row and the
third column now look at the matrix
first row and a third column it's minus
2 minus 2 is the 1 3 yet element of this
matrix and what about the 2 1 at element
second row and the first column but this
matrix has just one row so the 2 1 at
element does not exist let's quickly
review what we learned what is the order
of a matrix if it has m rows and n
columns the order will be M by n and not
the other way around and how is the
position of an element of a matrix
defined the row number first and then
the column number